you know I really like Vivek ramaswamy
he's a pal of mine we go back to college
together I think he's one of the most
exciting candidates in the GOP race I
like a lot of what he's saying and
calling for and the way he's shaking it
up I
I have to formally disavow my friend
Vivek I have to because
I I have a line okay my line it's not
how you feel about immigration my line
is not how you feel about tariffs or
something my line is
if you Embrace hip-hop
if you Embrace I can't I just can't
I can't bring myself to accept that and
Vivek did Embrace hip-hop he wasn't he
could have gotten on the stage at the
Iowa State Fair and started humming
along to the Brandenburg concertos he
could have gotten there
and pulled out of kazoo and started
humming Fur Elise but he didn't
he
wrapped Eminem
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a pretty convincing rendition I'm
not the I'm not the biggest Eminem fan
in the world so I don't know how it's
supposed to sound but
I I am impressed and horrified that
Vivek knows all of the words
and I am dismayed that the audience
appeared to like it so I just formally
for once and for all
this about my friend
it's very Charming it is very if I can
take my own prejudices out of it
it is very Charming to see a candidate
get up there and do that and even if you
don't like Eminem and even if you think
that's it's a little too performative or
something like that
this is why this guy is rising in the
polls is because he is taking risks all
the time all sorts of risks he's risking
his money on the campaign I think he
made a like a
an eight-figure donation to his own
political campaign
he is going out there taking unpopular
stances sometimes so then they become
popular stances he's debating
abortion Advocates on the campaign Trail
he's getting in the scrum everywhere he
he's going giving speeches and support
of uh Trump even though he's sometimes
going after Trump and distinguishing
himself from Trump he's supporting Trump
on the indictment stuff but then he'll
go after him and he'll go after other
candidates and he's just mixing it up
man
and the only way that you even have a
chance of becoming the GOP nominee in
2024 is if you take risks
and the other candidates are not doing
that
the the also Rands who are at single
digits right now
they're obviously not taking risks and
even Governor DeSantis who's who is in
the best position to take Trump out
I don't blame him as the candidate so
much as I blame the campaign
they're not taking the risks that they
need to and maybe that's on the
candidate too and sure the buck stops at
the candidate they've got to start
taking I'm not saying Rhonda Sanders
needs to get up and rap Eminem please
don't rap Eminem nobody in America
should rap Eminem but
the other GOP candidates could learn
from Vivek right now
it is not possible to win this race in a
safe way
you're either going to You're Gonna Take
a big risk and it's either going to pay
off and you're going to jump from number
seven in the race to number three or
maybe even number two
or you're going to flame out that's a
big risk it had that gone a different
way had he messed up the words a little
bit or had someone heckled him he would
have looked completely humiliated it
actually would have hurt but he took the
risk and
more importantly they're taking risks on
policy and they're taking risks on
places they're going to visit right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 as central
banks and countries like China India and
Australia begin transitioning to a
digital currency the Federal Reserve has
been contemplating the same for the U.S
with the digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make officials could even prohibit you
from purchasing certain products or
easily freeze or seize part or all of
your money these are some of the reasons
that concerned Americans have reached
out to Birch gold they want to have a
physical asset like gold that is
independent of the US dollar you can
protect your IRA or 401K by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold historically
gold has been a safe haven in times of
high uncertainty which is right now
learn if gold is right for you too text
Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98 they
will send you a free info kit on gold
with an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency times a reality it'll
be nice to have some gold to depend upon
right now text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98. right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles picture the perfect
Summer Night the warm breeze lapping
your face as you Lounge in your favorite
chair outside the grill is sizzling with
Juicy
hot burgers the aroma of the food is
irresistible
and now imagine what that perfect summer
night would look like
if you went to turn on the grill in your
propane tank were empty
huh that's where our friends at cinch
come in cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
delivery is totally contactless you do
not have to wait around at home track
the order from the Cinch app anywhere
whether you are grilling steaks or
lighting up patio heaters on a cold
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel that you
need to make the most of every moment go
to cinch.com or download the Cinch
c-y-n-c-h app to order new customers get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code nulls cinch.com or
download the Cinch app use promo code
notes for your first tank exchange for
just 10 bucks limited time offer you
must live with an essential service area
to redeem it cinch.com offer for details
meanwhile Trump shows up to the Iowa
fair and is warmly welcomed by the crowd
there was a clip that was going viral
there people seem to love them
four more years four more years you see
it now the the anti-trump people will
say well they weren't all there for
Trump and some people were there for
other candidates but
doesn't really matter guys because
every single poll
with the exception of Reuters every
single presidential poll right now has
shows the majority of Republicans
supporting Trump greater than 50 percent
and Reuters is a thing at 47 percent
and so I people sometimes accuse me of
flacking for
for
uh Trump I'm really not I'm really not
guys I'm describing the state of the
race right now
and
objectively describing the state of the
race might sound like flacking for Trump
because he is completely dominating the
race and the momentum is with him
so I don't I don't think that if you
want to if you support another candidate
and you want to win this race don't
shoot the messenger man you've got to
ask yourself why is Trump dominating
this I feel that most of my take on on
the 2024 has been hey Donald Trump is
absolutely crushing right now here's why
I think he's doing that and then the
supporters mostly of DeSantis but of
other candidates too will say well he
shouldn't be dominating I'll say yeah
maybe maybe I don't know whatever but he
is so here's why I think it stops saying
that he's dominating no he guys he just
is that is just a fact and if you want
to have even a snowball's chance in hell
at taking Trump out
then you need to at least begin to
understand why it is that he still has
support instead of just sneering at that
support and sneering at his supporters
that's what the GOP candidates all the
other candidates did in 2016
so Hillary Clinton did in 2016. people
still don't quite
get it boy what a great clip now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time